[Music]
Academia has fallen let me explain so
you're Franchesca Gino an award-winning
scientist and a professor at one of the
most prestigious universities in the
world Harvard as a professor you do not
care about making money as much as say
business people no one goes into
teaching or science for the money but
you are still human and what you do care
about is your status and how do you
increase your status as a professor
scientist well as a professor scientist
at a prestigious University like Harvard
people expect you to be making super big
discoveries super big discoveries that
change the way we see the world super
big discoveries that happen to make
Harvard look good and that also happen
to land you more publicity book deals
interviews Awards and admiration the
only problem is revolutionary scientific
discoveries are pretty hard to come by
many scientists go their entire careers
without making a single groundbreaking
discovery and even those that do only
get the chance once or twice in their
lifetime but you're desperate you want
to be remembered as one of the best
scientists of our time so you hatch up a
little plan to fudge the numbers a
little bit to change some of the numbers
here and there to make it it seem like
your studies are far more shocking and
revolutionary than they really are as a
celebrated academic no one's ever going
to suspect you of committing fraud and
plus as the lead researcher in these
studies committing fraud is so easy the
Temptation is hard to resist and so you
allegedly fudge the numbers never
expecting that you'll get caught but
eventually you did Professor Franchesca
Gino has been officially accused of
Faking the results in at least four of
her studies these Studies have been
referenced in books by famous authors by
companies in their marketing strategies
they've influenced an entire community
of scientists and researchers and
they've changed the way we understand
human behavior and in the academic world
these Studies have earned Franchesca
celebrity status but as it turns out it
was all based on lies and it gives us an
inside look on just how corrupt science
has become stay dangerous and this is
the fall of
Academia when you're in a classroom
setting like a university or you're in
your workplace or you're going for a run
often times you want to listen to music
but with traditional earphones you won't
be able to hear the the car that's about
to hit you or you won't hear your
colleagues trying to tell you something
and then boom you get hit by a car well
not anymore thanks to shocks shocks are
these professional open ear truly
wireless earbuds that are shockingly
good unlike traditional earphones shocks
have this open ear design so not only
can you hear every single little thing
around you but they're also infinitely
more comfortable even with airpods my
ears still get sore after only a few
hours but with shocks you can truly wear
them all day without any strain when I
first got these I was really nervous
about how they would sound but I was
genuinely surprised at how good they
sound and how Punchy the bass is the
quality really does sound on par
compared to normal earphones the one I
have is their open fit model and they
are now my go-to earbuds when I go
running because they feel super secure
in my ears because of the flexible ear
hook and you know I can hear cars coming
so if this sounds like something you've
been looking for then you got to give it
a try with the link below they've got a
45-day risk-free trial free shipping and
a 2-year warranty pick yourself today by
pausing the video and clicking the link
below thanks to shocks for sponsoring
this
video Franchesca goino is one one of the
most active Behavioral Science
researchers in her field since 2007 she
has published over 135 scientific
articles she's known for making these
wild theories when it comes to human
behavior and yet somehow her experiments
always seem to confirm these wild
theories which has made her one of the
most famous scientists of our times but
all of this success has made a lot of
people skeptical of her work in their
opinion G's theories and results have
always been a little bit too good to be
true but no one could figure out why
that was until Joe Simmons Leaf Nelson
and iie Simonson three business school
professors from other universities
decided to do a little digging into her
research to find out if she was actually
the real deal and it didn't take long
for these Three Investigators to find
some Starling irregularities in 2012
Gino and four other well-known
researchers published a report on a
study about honesty in the study they
were trying to figure out how to make
people more honest and here's how it
worked a group of students were brought
in and given a worksheet with 20 math
puzzles on it they were offered $1 for
each puzzle they got right within 5
minutes but here was the catch it's that
the students were allowed to grade
themselves and then they were allowed to
shred their worksheets so no one would
be able to check if they lied or not
about how many answers they got right
the idea was to make students think that
they could cheat and get away with it
once they had shredded their worksheets
each student was given another form to
report the amount of money they had
earned from the puzzles they solved the
only difference in the study was that
some other the students got a form with
an honesty pledge at the top some other
students got a form with an honesty
pledge at the bottom and some students
got a form with no honesty pledge at all
what the people in the experiment don't
know is that we played with the
shredder
talking talking about cheating
um the shredder Shred the sides of the
page so when you put the page in it
vibrates it shakes it makes a sound but
the body of the page remains
intact so we can find out how many
questions people really solve correctly
Gino's theory was that if students
signed the honesty pledge at the top of
the form it would make them more honest
and when the results came back that's
exactly what the study proved while
while 79% of the students who signed at
the bottom lied about the number of
puzzles they solved only about 37% of
the students who signed at the top lied
so the honesty pledge at the top of the
form clearly worked Gina wasn't just
correct she was wildly correct achieving
the highly sought after statistical
significance statistical significance
means that the results of your study are
likely true and not due to chance and at
first thought this Theory kind of makes
sense but when you st to think about it
really signing a stupid pledge is going
to double your chances of being honest a
person who is set on cheating is not
going to cheat just because they signed
the stupid pledge it seems at least a
little bit too good to be true right
that's what the Three Investigators
looking into gos set to find out so they
took a closer look at the data and they
noticed something was really off here's
a spreadsheet of all the participants
and as you can see these results are
almost perfectly sorted by their
participant ID except for the few
results highlighted in yellow these
results are completely random out of
order and one of the participants is
even mentioned twice participant number
49 hm okay that's a little weird but
what if someone just made a mistake when
they were entering the data that could
be the case but what's even more
suspicious is that these entries also
had the biggest effects on the results
of the study these suspicious entries
all heavily skewed the results in favor
of goo's Theory without them her Theory
would not have any legs to stand on
there wouldn't be any statistical
significance and after examining the
history of the Excel sheets the
investigator's suspicions were confirmed
someone had indeed fudged the numbers by
changing a few lines in the spreadsheet
someone was able to turn what would have
been a pretty lackluster study into
something Sensational a study that would
be published into top journals that will
be mentioned in the morning news that
would bring in Lads of publicity
interviews attention and praise and that
someone was probably Franchesca Gino but
there were a lot of people involved in
the study so how can we know for sure
that it was her that fudged the numbers
well that is right if this was the only
case it would be a little hard to prove
that it was indeed her that did this but
those Three Investigators were just
getting
[Music]
started
Franchesca Gina was part of another
study about honesty in 2015 this time
her theory was that arguing against
something you believe in would make you
feel dirty and therefore it would
increase your desire for cleaning
products as a result it seems like a
pretty silly hypothesis but think about
it if proven right news stations from
all over the country would be touting
[Music]
how did you know that lying makes you
more likely to buy cleaning products
joining us now is Professor Esa Gino who
just completed another landmark study
saying just that maybe you can even do a
Ted Talk on it ah yes you can see it now
your name up in lights so you did the
study and magically just like before
your theory was proven wildly right as
part of the study around 500 students
completed an online survey to express
their opinion on a polarizing issue
about Harvard then they were asked to
write an essay that either argued for or
against the opinion they just stated
after the essay each student was asked
to rate how desirable they found five
different cleaning products and as
expected a ton of more students who
argued against their beliefs ended up
finding the cleaning products more
desirable compared to the honest group
and once again the difference between
these two groups was massive goo's
theory was proven correct Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt Shia once again
achieved statistical significance until
our Three Investigators sourced the
original data online and just like in
the first study some of the data seemed
a little fishy as part of the study
students were asked to answer three
simple demographic questions one of the
questions asked for the students year in
school and that's where things got a
little weird obviously there are a lot
of ways you can answer this question
students could have written senior or
junior or they could have put they were
in the class of 2015 or something or
they could have just put the number of
years they had been at Harvard all these
answers would have made perfect sense
but the investigators came across
something strange grouped together in
just 35 rows a bunch of students had
apparently just answered Harvard hey
what year school are you in oh Harvard
it made zero sense and there was no way
so many students could get such an easy
answer so wrong especially not Harvard
students so the investigator took the
suspicious results and plotted them on a
graph and just like before all those
fishy entries were also some of the most
extreme entries that skewed the results
in favor of her Theory it was obvious
that someone had gone back into the
original results the lead that
information for a few students and then
re-entered data that would support their
hypothesis and maybe as they were doing
this they had forgotten what the last
question was and just entered Harvard
instead and once again it was Franchesca
Gino who had published the final result
of the study online Professor Gino was
looking more and more guilty by the
minutes but even with two obvious cases
as good as proven our Three
Investigators still had one trick up
their
[Music]
sleeves for the next study our Three
Investigators didn't even have to go far
to find the original data because Gino
has sent them the data herself just a
few years ago this time Gino and her
fellow researchers hypothesized that
people who are dishonest are more
creative than those who aren't to test
their Theory they created a simple
online experiment around 180
participants will be presented with a
virtual coin toss and then they would be
asked to predict whether the coin will
show heads or tails when it lands for
every correct guess they would be paid
$1 just like the first study this gave
participants an easy opportunity to
cheat and make more money but little did
they know that the researchers would be
able to see the number of times each
participant had cheated after the coin
toss exercise the participants were
asked to list out as many uses for a
newspaper as possible in 1 minute the
more creative the participant was the
more uses they would be able to think of
for the newspaper by now you can
probably guess what the results were the
participants who cheated ended up being
more creative by a long run and again
Professor Gino's theories were proven
right but with the original data at
their fingertips it didn't take our
Three Investigators long to spot another
set of suspicious results in the Excel
sheet the results have first been sorted
according to who had cheated and who
hadn't and then by the number of uses
they could find for a newspaper and just
like before the investigators found a
whole bunch of entries that seemed
completely out of order as if someone
had gone back and changed the number of
newspaper uses so the results look more
dramatic and just like before the
investigators were proven rights each of
the altered results was there to inflate
the data and when you change the
suspicious results back to the numbers
they should have been according to where
they were sorted on the sheets there was
actually no difference between the
cheaters and the non-cheaters creativity
Franchesca Gino had done it again but
Gino wasn't going to go down without a
fight
[Music]
in the fall of 2021 our Three
Investigators compiled a for report on
their findings and suspicions based on
those four studies of gos and they sent
it to the Harvard Business School for
review Harvard would have a lot more
access and insights into the studies
Gino had done and they would be able to
figure out pretty easily if someone had
changed the results the investigators
suspected that there were a lot more
studies than just those four as well and
apparently they weren't wrong Harvard's
internal report on what happened was
more than 1200 pages long that's a lot
of pages for just four studies as a
result Franchesca Gina was put on unpaid
administrative leave and her four
studies were retracted but Gina wasn't
going to take these accusations lying
down instead she's suing these three
professors and Harvard University for at
least $25 million arguing that this was
all defamation but she made one small
mistake with the details of her lawsuit
made public we now know that Harvard's
investigation found solid proof that she
had been altering the results herself
for at least one of the studies the
original and manipulated Excel sheets
have been created and last safe by Gino
herself proving without a doubt that she
was the one responsible so if you're
going to be like Professor Gino and fake
your results to gain more status at
least put a little bit of effort into
modifying your spreadsheet at least copy
and paste your data over to a fresh new
Excel sheet so that the history is clean
and I know where you're thinking but
Jake it's pretty easy to fix stuff in
the soft Sciences like Behavioral
Science but what about the hard Sciences
like physics and biology there's no way
you can commit research fraud with that
well you would be sadly
mistaken
[Music]
this is Mark Tessier LaVine the
president of Stanford University he's
one of the most well-known and respected
academics in the world and he has also
just been accused of research fraud Mark
is a neuroscientist who's famous for his
work in the 90s that studied how brain
cells work his research had massive
implications for doctors trying to treat
Alzheimer's and building on that he
worked himself up through the ranks
eventually becoming president of
Rockefeller University in 201
and then the president of Stanford in
2016 but Mark's career had not always
been a smooth climb to the top over and
over again people pointed out issues
with the research he published and by
the time he became president of Stanford
rumors of malpractice in his lab have
been swirling around for years but
here's the thing despite all these
accusations Mark had become a massive
figure in the academic Community
accusing him without solid proof would
be career suicide so even though plenty
of people had their suspicions no one
ever had the guts to investigate him
until now what's the even creaser is
that the person that exposed Mark wasn't
some Professor or researcher no it was
an 18-year-old Stanford freshman named
Theo Baker Theo was part of the
University student run newspaper the
Stanford daily and in 2022 he made it
his mission to do what people twice his
age have been too scared to try for
years he would take on one of the most
powerful scientists in the
[Music]
world with the help of Elizabeth Bick a
bi ologist and scientific fraud
investigator Deo started digging into
Mark's most questionable studies and
what he found was close to unbelievable
without going into too many details of
the complicated research marks Labs
conducted Theo and elizeth discovered
that much of the photographic evidence
have been shamelessly altered and when I
say shamelessly I mean shamelessly like
here where the results in the purple and
green squares are repeated in photos for
a totally separate experiment meaning
they just copy and paste a photo from
one experiment to another or like here
will the contents of the yellow and
green squares have obviously been copied
and used to cover something up the
manipulations got so out of hand that in
one study they literally reused the
exact same photo but just artificially
enlarged it to show a neuron growing
like it's literally the same photo just
zoomed in a bit the old baker published
his findings in 2022 and it caused chaos
in the scientific Community the
president of one of the best
universities in the world was a liar and
a fraud but just like Franchesca Gino
mark would not go down without a fights
and unlike her he had Stanford
University on his
side
[Music]
turn up the volume for this one last
week we told you about the president of
Stanford University announcing he would
be stepping down it is because of
questions about some of his past
research those questions were first
brought into the Spotlight by the
student paper the Stanford daily and our
next guest is the student journalist who
broke that story Theo Baker almost as
soon as Theo Baker findings were
published Stanford University went into
damage control they announced an
investigation into Mark's Work they also
quickly made a statement saying that
most of the manipulated research had no
effect on the study's results Stanford
didn't want to tarnish their prestigious
reputation so they played down Mark's
involvement when the investigation ended
after 8 months the official report was
that Mark had done nothing wrong it said
that there was no evidence that Mark
himself had been involved in
manipulating the data or that he knew
about the fraudulent data either ah yes
an institution's task with investigating
itself finds this not guilty what a
surprise but even if Mark wasn't the one
that did it Mark was still listed on
each of these studies as a co-author and
usually co-authors are really involved
in writing and reviewing the reports
before they're published people have
pointed out issues with Mark's Work in
2001 the early 2010s 2015 2016 and even
2021 and not once had he made any
attempt to correct these mistakes
because why would he as president of
Stanford he was making a wiping $1.5
million a year and another $700,000 as a
a director of a biotech company called
regeneron him becoming the president of
the Stanford University is basically the
equivalent of a political science
student eventually becoming the
president of the country he was at the
top and he was not going to risk giving
that up in July 2023 Mark announced that
he would be resigning as staner
president and he would be retracting at
least three of his papers and even
though it was obvious why he was
resigning he made sure to tell everyone
that it had nothing to do with these
accusations and that he only resigned
because he believed Stanford needed a
leader that wasn't shrouded in all these
false accusations thanks to Stanford's
support Mark got off easy and he won't
even be leaving the university
completely he will stay on as a faculty
member while also keeping a spot as a
director of
[Music]
regeneron science is viewed as this
infallible thing that science can't be
corrupted trust in the science they say
but at the end of the day scientists are
still humans and as humans who could say
no to the publicity the recognition the
tenure ship at a great University so you
can have job security for the rest of
your life especially when cheating is oh
so easy we would hope to think that
Franchesca and Mark were the only
prominent academics to have cheated but
let's be real these are just the two
that actually got caught so who knows
how many other fraudulent studies there
are out there that we have shaped
society around that have not been
exposed stay dangerous and we'll see you
in the next
one
[Music]